what computing about this is that this
is supposed to be faster comment in here
but this first time I've ever changed to
you it will look slower so be patient ok
the reason why I called me the purchase
what they are is because the one has no
choice but to go all on the ground
slowly and just chew through it like you
my dear that's literally ones doing the
vibe approach is slow take to the end
look at the whole thing from day one to
the end of you five or at once ok if you
think about that way I want you to look
at the sums of money that you've got it
I want you to look at this founder
dollars this thousand dollars this
thousand dollars this Arnold and this
thousand dollars okay I'm going to look
at it in reverse
watch carefully this is a simple
question but Kimberly see this one down
the dollars here how much interested
again this particular bathroom it
doesn't get any interest at all you can
see because I never multiply it by 1.09
knows that like it never gets it a bit
applied to it okay so the reason why is
because this is in there for 0 years
right if we were in there for 1 years
get one year's worth of interest but
this happens at the end of the 50 years
so that's why you just stays without the
knows no interest how do we do this
thousand dollars do you notice it gets
folded into a four it becomes part of a
four yeah so look see on this line one
of its in a four how many times does it
get interest one once because how long
has this thousand dollars being in there
it's been in there for what you okay did
you see what's going on now have a look
at this down two dollars you put it in
at the end of year three so you put it
in and then give four passes and then
years five passes so how many years is
it invert and you can climb all the way
back and eventually you find you got
five different chunks of money okay so
once you imagine
has a good to look at a bird's eye view
there are five different chunks of money
each of which goes into their different
job and you can see how much interests a
teach game okay this is about the looks
moment but eventually we will cut away
to four Dementors I can say what my
clothes I'm going to call it an s-curve
some there's this song here right some
reports on number one and it's just
about dollars if the youngest and get no
interest so that's all that equals I'm
going back in time some number two this
guy here right
he gets one year how do I apply interest
for one year we've seen it already on
the bottom it's the one thousand dollars
and you multiply by 1.09 do you agree is
compound interest rate so when you have
a look at this sets up here here right
again it was a thousand dollars again he
gets the same night interest of having
time twice right do you remember what
the compound interest where does at the
time it would sit there do your great
empowerment
if the power of that interest right is
1.9 I have tons of 0.09 again you don't
need to do that the sport one I'm almost
there it's going to get the same lot of
interest in how many times right device
and then you'll ask your ordered sum of
money the original set of money it gets
for you to decide are you following with
me
so therefore going back to my original
notation of a that the total man your
total amount is this and this and this
and this it is all added up together
that's it okay now field of the moment
like this is a longer way to do it it is
the way that I've said lot but when you
get into your waiter exercises you will
get a team
that will calculate all of these numbers
for you you don't have to do any numbers
punching punching you just look at the
table okay
but I need you to see the concept where
it comes from what did the web do we
won't just slowly go through one year
time one extra sum of money what
interest an extra some interest and just
chews through the third looks at the
whole situation from the top right and
so how does interest is each of these
thousand dollar chomps good again and
you can work plants just like thinking
about one so I'm going to add these all
together because each year has what
thousand dollars and maybe check the
thing that interests you will get the
same thing at the end you're more than
welcome to punch it into your calculator
whoops
people punch into your calculator and
verify okay so you need to be able to do
both of these you need to be able to do
both of those okay the key for you is to
look at keywords in more than just
compound interest this is about
continually putting in extra sums of
money which is why we can get so
enormous by the end ok there are
questions make sense is a clear thunder
decided okay I'll just write up how many
in for base I'm going to put these like
a little what about it plus a thousand
plans 1.09 don't flush I want to thank
you my darling in twelve this will save
you some time so I want you to watch
this carefully
wladim you get a handy goal yeah if
you'll put this into your calculator do
you've notice then you have to press the
cover in five times hundred times of
incident only there a way to think about
taking some sort of common factor and
Bill having to write it in multiple
times a way we call it when they become
a backlog
come on company hi guys all right we
call it factorizing so what now no
rather than writing it over over and
over again
is one of them here and then there's one
point nine of them here and then there's
one point
squared of them here and honking people
are going going and they've done okay
now just stare harder to p2 the finitude
to achievement or an extension one they
never do it up to four you're like
maritime damage I feel like 40 or 50 or
400 but obviously for their numbers they
have to develop a super sophisticated
technique to a handle numbers like that
which is something you do not feel
worried about it
so these are all within the reach of
your calculator thing is to actually
evaluate and you will get yes you'll get
five does not really for and so everyone
says you know what